this day and age it appears that every
super tom dick and harry gets an origin
story I'm holding out for aren't made
the series but until then at least
there's the possibility of a show about
Superman granddad no seriously I'm Simon
and this is your super-powered news
update following the success of shows
such as arrow and the flash Warner is
looking to produce another series based
on its DC properties it has been
reported that cable channel sci-fi is
close to green lighting a pilot for a
Superman origin story called Krypton
according to The Hollywood Reporter the
show is nearing a pickup by the channel
which is also the home of such other
sci-fi fantasy shows such as twelve
Monkeys z nation and hunters Krypton has
been developed by David s Goyer who
co-wrote both Batman V Superman dawn of
justice and man of steel four DC as well
as Christopher Nolan's Batman movies and
the Constantine TV show the new series
would focus not on Superman but on
Superman's grandfather and his attempts
to bring peace to the Kryptonian
homeworld in an interview with Collider
last year boya spoke about his plans for
the show in terms of production value
you have to pick your moments he said
should we make the show they will
definitely be some big moments it won't
be wall-to-wall visual effects every
single moment spectacle in the way the
film will be but we'll be digging into
the characters and the culture a lot
more unlike Marvel DC's various shows
which includes Supergirl legends of
tomorrow and Gotham do not all exist
within the same universe and are very
much separate to its big screen
offerings it is unknown whether Krypton
will bisect with any other current shows
or if it will be a standalone series
could you see Krypton as one of your
favorite TV shows would you rather see a
sitcom about krypto the superdog let me
know in the comments or come find me on
Twitter I'm at the journal thanks for
watching and for all your entertainment
news keep it gamespot
I